[Music]
when i started my vfx journey back in
2006 i thought the most inspiring thing
about 3d art was the fact that if i
could think it i could create it
and if i dedicated myself to becoming
proficient in whatever 3d program i'd
only be limited by my imagination
16 years later and that idea still has
me excited to create and the duration
between what's in my head and what
eventually gets created on a screen only
gets shorter the more time i create
so in this video i'm going to show you
specifically how you can bring your
imagination to life in as little time as
possible we'll set up our camera the
environment and our lighting together to
hit that 80 mark as soon as possible so
we can spend most of our time on the fun
tweaks and details that really make our
art shine we'll set up some fully
customizable foliage that we can paint
over our environment and after that i'll
get into the best practices for the
highest quality exports so whether
you're an experienced 3d artist new to
the whole thing or just have a curiosity
for it all i welcome you to sit back and
enjoy the process
[Music]
before starting any project no matter
how big or small i gather reference
imagery and view it all in a free
program called pureref once i have my
general direction my next goal is to get
to that 80 mark let's get started and
quickly set up our project in unreal
engine 5. it doesn't matter too much
which level preset you go with i just
need something super simple so i'll go
with games and the blank preset
i'll toggle starter content so we have
some building blocks to build our scene
with and even though unreal engine 5
defaults to lumen the new light system
which we'll be using for our scene i'm
going to toggle ray tracing anyway
because it's honestly a pain in the rear
to enable all these hidden rtx settings
by hand this way it's all set up
automatically if you want to use like
raytraced shadows or something but if
this makes no sense don't worry let's
just open up our project to navigate i'm
holding right-click and using the was
and d keys to fly around the q and e
keys control altitude and the slider on
the right controls camera sensitivity
with an object selected spacebar will
cycle between the position rotation and
scale gizmos control plus backtick
switches between world and local
orientation the g key will hide or show
icons in the viewport and f will snap
your view to any selected object so now
that we're in let's get to that 80 mark
starting with the camera
on the left you should see the place
actors window if not go to window place
actors this is where we'll find a lot of
unreal's built-in tools or building
blocks to help us create stuff in our
scene let's search for cine camera actor
drag it in right click it in the
outliner which is where all the stuff in
our scene is laid out and select pilot
camera to hop in i'm also going to
search for cube in our place actors
window so we have something to focus on
and i'll just scale it to resemble a
door looking thing now i'm setting up
our camera and camera angle first so we
don't waste time building stuff we're
not going to see so with our camera
selected in the details panel i'll
choose my aspect ratio my focal length
and my aperture also known as f-stop
which controls our depth of field and
under focus settings we can set it to
track our door that way wherever the
camera is it'll always be focused on the
door itself and i'd say after we frame
up our scene the camera is set up enough
so that we can move on to laying out the
environment
and the thing that makes unreal engines
so powerful are all the 3d assets and
textures that come free with the program
you can access the mega scans library
here by clicking qixel bridge but to
keep things moving i just preloaded some
ground floors walls embankments some
logs and a door just to note that these
are nanite meshes which is new to unreal
5 and definitely some dark voodoo that
allows us to have a ton of these assets
in our scene while still maintaining a
high frame rate which you can see by
clicking show fps right here from here
i'll build out my scene based on the
idea i'm going for
this will require a little bit of back
and forth to get things looking right
but remember we're going for 80 so don't
get too hung up on the details if things
look a little empty that's okay because
we're gonna go and fill this environment
with a bunch of lush foliage later one
thing i do want to do though is open up
this door to make things a bit more
mysterious but this clip is in the way
so we're gonna need to cut a door sized
hole into this wall so let's grab our
placeholder door stretch it out switch
over to the modeling layout on the left
here select both the rock we're trying
to cut into and your cube and select
mesh bull you might need to switch
between a cuts b or b cuts a and after
your computer thinks for a bit we got a
doorway into another world but i want it
to lead to a dark room so let's press
control spacebar to open up our content
browser now this is where all of our
imported assets tools and building
blocks are stored i'll search for wall
which is going to tap into our starter
content and i'm going to drag that out
duplicate it a few times and make a
little room to block all the light but
once i got my room i'll place a couple
rock wall assets inside so it's not just
a white room and at this point i think
we got our environment to the 80 mark
which is plenty to work in the last
major element our lighting
and to best judge our lighting we got to
turn off this auto exposure so in the
place actors window i'm going to search
for what's called a post process volume
and drag it out the ppv is a global
effector that lets us adjust light
settings render settings color
correction camera effects and a bunch of
other stuff but to make sure it affects
our entire level and not just this
little box we need to search for unbound
in the details panel and turn on
infinite extent then let's search for
brightness and set the min max to the
same amount
bam auto exposure dealt with so let's
take a quick look at the things
currently lighting our scene we have a
directional light that's acting as our
main sunlight and without it we would
have no light at all
and the skylight is helping with
indirect illumination and overall
brightness and the sky atmosphere is
kind of doing the same but i honestly
didn't touch it for my scene or any of
these other ones now i want to go for a
gloomier overcast look with maybe some
soft light spotlighting this door so
first i'll point the sun at our door
then set up some walls to block the
light across our entire scene except on
the door
and just so we're not bouncing white
light all over the place with these
white walls i'll apply one of these moss
wall textures onto them and it doesn't
matter that they don't look good only
that they're bouncing forest colors
sweet so we got that dialed in next
let's set up our overcast light with an
hdri which is basically a 360 image that
lights our entire scene but to do this
we got to enable the plugin by going to
settings plugins typing hdri toggling
the setting and restarting the engine
and once we're back i'll search for hdri
in the place actors window drag it into
my scene reset the position if necessary
and drop it down below my floor bam easy
as that so now we'll combine both lights
by turning our directional light back on
and adjusting its source angle in the
details panel which will soften the
shadows giving us a nice blend between
overcast and sunlight you can adjust and
balance the intensity of both your
directional light and hdri as needed and
feel free to turn the brightness up or
down a touch in your post process volume
too and while we're here let's search
for vignette to add some of it as well
as color correction so we can drop the
gamma a touch this will give us like a
moodier feel that i really like
and with that i think we've hit our 80
mark for the entire image so i started
this channel
16 years ago
and i am almost at a million
subscribers so if you're watching this
video and you're learning something
that's entertaining for you and you're
not subscribed
consider subscribing let's get to a
million
from here we'll be adding details and
making small adjustments between the
lighting the camera and of course the
environment which is still missing an
assortment of lush vegetation but before
we paint any vegetation we need to set
up a customizable vegetation material
that you can use across all your
projects asset wise i'll be using the
forest the world's pack by graswalt the
sponsor of today's video grasswold
offers production quality vegetation
assets for your games your films and
your 3d art what makes these assets so
unique and realistic is the fact that
the grass ball team travels to unique
locations to scan and document specific
vegetation that defines that specific
environment so their 3d reconstructions
are as accurate to the real world as
possible that means we don't have to
guess which 3d plants go together
everything naturally blends together
because it was captured together most of
their assets offer a small and big
variation and some even come with old
and dead variations too each asset comes
with its individual building blocks to
make customization virtually limitless
and of course each plant has its
appropriate image textures in 1k 2k and
4k resolution options they each have
eight levels of detail and each pack is
pre-built in nearly every renderer in
every 3d program on their website which
is linked in the description you can
grab a few plants they offer for free
but if you want to get your hands on
their entire pack you can get 20 off for
this week only by clicking that link in
the description and using the code
punisher promo 2022
but regardless of what asset you're
using let's create this fully
customizable vegetation master material
that you can use on any piece of
vegetation in any level in any project
let's dive in so let's import the mesh
that the material is going to go on
first which we can just drag and drop
into the content browser
usually i generate a nanite mesh for
nearly any mesh you bring in but nanite
doesn't work with foliage right now more
on that in a second but if your mesh
comes with other meshes of varying
detail called lods or levels of detail
be sure to auto import them because
we're going to scatter a ton of these
assets and it's better to drop the level
of detail on these things if it gets
laggy
let's also drag our image textures into
the content browser the plant mesh into
our assets level and right click in the
content browser to create a new material
titled foliage master material drag it
onto our mesh double click it to open up
our material editor and we're in all
right by default we're not seeing the
underside of this foliage and that is no
bueno so let's click double sided and
hit save to update that's the part that
nanite doesn't support by the way is
double-sided and two-sided foliage in
order for us to get the sun to shine
through our foliage which is a huge part
of realistic vegetation we need to
change the shading method to two-sided
foliage which unlocks the subsurface
color option in our material
again make sure to hit save for these
changes to take effect and finally we'll
change our blending mode to mask which
unlocks the opacity mask channel saving
us a bit of performance now let's drag
our textures in and set them up one by
one starting with base color otherwise
known as albedo and it's as simple as
dragging the rgb into the base color
channel but i want to have control over
the brightness of this texture so hold s
and left click to make a parameter node
you're gonna hear me say parameter or
parameter node a lot parameters are
basically settings we can quickly adjust
when we eventually create an instance of
this master material later but for now
let's hold m and left click to make a
multiply node which will pipe into base
color and both of these nodes into the
multiply let's default our brightness to
1 which will have no effect which is
exactly what we're going for
a value of 0 gets darker 2 gets brighter
and it's as easy as that select your
base color nodes and press c to group
them next is specular which determines
how reflective our vegetation is
just right click specular and convert it
to a parameter with a default of 0.5
next we'll drag our roughness texture
which controls how matte versus shiny
our leaves are and it's a great way to
control how wet the leaves look we'll
control the roughness intensity in the
same way we did our base color we can
default it to one which gives us a matte
effect and the closer we get to zero the
sharper the reflection c to group and
we're set
opacity is next whatever's white is
opaque whatever's black is transparent
we plug this into the opacity mask
channel and even though it doesn't make
a visible difference on our mesh it
saves just a tiny bit of performance so
it's good practice versus just plugging
it into the plain old opacity channel up
next is our normal map which essentially
gives us fake detail and we'll control
its intensity a bit differently this
time with a lerp node a constant three
vector node and a parameter node the
lerp node asks for two different inputs
in our case a normal map and a blue
solid and the alpha controls which
direction to go in
setting our normal intensity parameter
to zero tells the lerp to view only the
blue solid which essentially turns off
our normal detail
one should be our default setting which
yields the same result as if we just
plugged our normal texture directly into
the normal channel and beyond a setting
of one it just gets more intense hence
our normal intensity parameter
the last and most important image
texture for foliage is translucency
which controls the amount of light that
shines through our leaves again this is
how real leaves behave so don't miss
this step and if you don't have a
translucency texture you can substitute
your base color image i'm controlling
its intensity the same way we set up our
roughness and our base color textures
with the multiply node your default
value will depend on your specific
texture but i'm going for a value of
0.25
and plants aren't plants without some
wind now this took me more than a minute
to figure out if you're familiar with
how quiksil sets up their wind this is
exactly the same but actually way easier
to set up shout outs to the prismatica
dev youtube channel which really helped
me make sense of it all in the end
alright so let's right click and search
for a simple grass wind node and right
click each of these settings to convert
them to parameters i'll default the
intensity to 0.15 height to 0.5 speed to
0.5 and world position offset to 0. and
if we plug this into the world position
offset channel and hit save you can see
it's kind of working but it might as
well just be floating in space because
it's not fixed to the ground now we can
solve this the hard way or the easy way
with a bounding box uv node with the
blue channel which correlates to the
vertical axis plugged into a multiply
which goes into the world position
offset of our master material
it works and it's so simple i love it
this works on any plant regardless of
the size too but i want our foliage to
default to no wind with the option of
checking a box to turn it on so i'll
make a switch parameter with our wind
plugged into true and a parameter set to
zero as false making sure the switch
defaults to unchecked plug that into
your world position offset and we're
basically all set up
so the moment of truth let's save close
out right click the master material and
create a material instance which will be
the actual material assigned to our mesh
so be sure to open up that mesh and drag
here to assign
let's save and check out these custom
controls that we just set up
i love the feeling i get from setting up
a useful master material it's a step
beyond creating your art because we're
actually creating custom tools to help
us create art super satisfying but yo i
am ocd and this
is just a mess so let me show you how to
organize your parameters in the material
instance real quick
back in the master material if we
control click all of our texture
parameters and change the group to
something like texture attributes and
save
you can see they're grouped as such we
can do the same for the wind parameters
too and just like we can convert
settings to parameters we can do the
same for textures too that way we can
duplicate the instance switch out the
textures and now you have control over a
whole new type of plant do this for as
many plant variations you have in your
scene and we'll be good to go hey i got
a question for you guys do you enjoy the
step-by-step click-by-click kind of
tutorials or do you prefer more of an
overview regardless of what the program
is
i'm curious to know your guys's answers
leave a comment down below but alright
so now that we've completed our setup
and got to that 80 mark let's do what
we've been waiting for get back to the
art and fill our landscape with this
beautiful foliage
let's switch to foliage mode up here and
drag the meshes you want to paint or
scatter across your environment into the
foliage box making sure the ones you
want to paint are checked i'll select
them all to reveal some options we can
customize like min and max values for
size variation how steep the ground
needs to be to accept the foliage
density which controls how close these
plants are to each other when painted
and up top we have brush size as well
and just paint to your heart's content
holding left click will lay down our
vegetation you can shift click to erase
adjust the brush size with the bracket
keys and toggle single instance mode set
the cycle through selected to
individually place plants for the most
control
drop some new assets in uncheck the old
ones and paint a variety for a more
realistic look so we did the hard work
we set up the sandbox to freely create
inside of adding details will take the
most time but it's the best part of the
process because we get to spontaneously
create laying the tracks as we go it's
when the images in our heads seamlessly
blend into the art on screen it's the
reason i love to create whether it's
making 3d art or improving music with
friends it just feels so good when
things work out on the fly the more we
practice the faster all that setup gets
too and the quicker this stage comes so
let's talk about all the things you'll
likely be tweaking at this point in the
process mainly lighting camera settings
camera position material attributes and
in this case our foliage
i want to bring a bit more shape to our
scene and try to make the ground look
wet by creating a rectangle light which
will skip off the floor
and if we drop the intensity we can
start to get that subtle wet look but
the only reason we're seeing a
reflection is because of the specular
and roughness channels the higher your
specular the more reflective the lower
your roughness the sharper your
reflection will be
so be sure to adjust this wetness look
on your foliage as well and you can
tweak the translucency too if the plants
are looking a bit too bright i'll hop
into the post process volume and tweak
the gamma and vignette to get the right
vibe then back to my directional light
intensity my hdri intensity my rectangle
light intensity maybe i'll add another
overhead rack light to give my scene a
slightly different vibe maybe another
one to really pop the door out i'll mess
with my camera's depth of field settings
too if an angle with my focal length a
touch perhaps we tweak all these things
to find the right balance between too
much and too little what you think looks
good today may not work tomorrow and you
might think you're done one day but wake
up the next and feel like something's
missing so take breaks sleep on it and
ask a friend for their opinion so you
can return to your 3d world with a fresh
perspective nine times out of ten your
art will be better because of it
but when you're happy with your art how
do we render what's in our viewport to a
high res video well if you want to
export a still image the fastest way is
by exporting a high resolution
screenshot you can adjust the size
multiplier to multiply the image size
but go easy on this else you want to
start a fire
but chances are you're trying to export
a video so we need to make a timeline of
sorts in order for unreal to know
there's a sequence to be exported so
we'll right click in the content browser
navigate to animation and create a level
sequence
double click to hop in and drag our
camera inside
from here you can set the overall frame
length and animate a small camera move
to spice things up basically anything
that needs to be animated happens here
in the sequencer
and once you have the shot you're going
for there's a number of render settings
you can use for best results and the
first thing you want to do to get that
set up is go to settings plugins search
for the movie render queue enable these
plugins and restart your engine so that
when you click the little dot dots next
to this little clapboard in the
sequencer movie render queue will be an
option so let's hop in and click
settings to tweak our settings and click
settings to tweak our settings nice
first we'll add an exr sequence set to
dwaa compression for the most control
over our image during color correction
which means we don't really need this
jpeg sequence next i'll add
anti-aliasing set the temporal sample
count to something between 32 and 64.
keeping in mind it'll have to render
this amount of frames per every single
frame in your sequence so it'll take a
lot longer but it gets rid of this
blurry look on our foliage in the
viewport caused by the wind
finally just check the override
anti-aliasing box and we're done with
that
next is the secret sauce the cheat codes
that crank your render settings to the
max yes we are talking about console
commands
in the comments i pin my favorite ones
for the very best so feel free to copy
paste them as individual console
commands here the only thing i'll
mention is the screen percentage command
let's say we tell unreal engine to
export a 2k image by setting screen
percentage to 100 it'll do just that but
if you set it to 200 it'll render a 4k
image scaled down to fit inside your 2k
resolution ultimately making your image
crisper and packed with more detail so i
like keeping mine somewhere between 150
and 200. and finally we have output
where we can select our path resolution
like we just talked about custom frame
rate which i'll set to 24 and custom
frame range if you need it be sure to
save these settings as a preset before
closing out though and then you can
watch the frames roll in
add some subtle color correction and
film grain in davinci resolve and we got
ourselves a pretty sweet final result
16 years ago when i first got into 3d it
took years to get to the point where i
could truly create what i saw in my
mind's eye
today with this kind of workflow and a
little bit of practice it can take just
hours
and maybe one day
the immersive worlds we visit in our
imagination can be created in the blink
of an eye
thanks for watching everybody
keep learning keep growing and stay
inspired
[Music]
you